hello everyone I'm Sean Carroll and
welcome to this special bonus video in
which I try to shamelessly convince you
to become a patreon supporter of the
mindscape podcast the podcast itself
which is not video it's just audio as
you probably know is available for free
and always will be you can always listen
to it you have to pay anything but if
you become a patreon supporter you get a
couple of extra goodies the most obvious
ones of which are you get to have an ad
free version of the podcast and also you
get to contribute to questions that I
tackle in the monthly ask me anything
episodes there's also some sort of more
vague intangible benefit of supporting a
good cause and being part of the
conversation that goes on in the comment
sections Etc this video illustrates one
more little benefit that we're
experimenting with I think it's going to
go forward but we'll see how it is which
is a reflection video that I do after
each podcast so the podcasts are audio
but after each podcast I'll do just a
couple minutes of reflection in which I
I say a little bit about why I chose
this person or what I thought about the
conversation or other places to go and
so forth nothing very deep but a little
bit of reflection on the podcast that
just happened so this is an example just
to wet your appetite freely available
this one but the other ones you got to
go to patreon for a dollar an episode
four bucks a month something like that
you get this wonderful little bit of
extra content so this is the reflection
video associated with the podcast I did
with Tim bodlin who's a philosopher of
science an expert in the foundations of
quantum mechanics
it was great to have Tim Maudlin on the
podcast at last I've been meaning to
have Tim on for a long time Tim is
clearly one of the world's leading
philosophers of physics a worker a
researcher in foundations of quantum
mechanics statistical mechanics Arrow of
time all these things that I care about
a lot for those of you who are not in
the community there's a very very active
tight-knit group of philosophers of
physics in the New York New Jersey area
between Rutgers NYU and Colombia
especially with uh at Rutgers Barry
lower who we've had on the podcast also
people like Shelly Goldstein at NYU Tim
Tim used to be at Rutgers then he moved
to NYU and then David Albert of course
at Columbia they all interact with each
other talk with each other all the time
the great thing about Tim is he's super
duper smart always worth talking to and
I disagree with him about just about
everything when it comes to the
philosophy of physics but it's still
very worthwhile talking to
happily in the podcast we actually
mostly dwelled on things that I agree
with him about in terms of why it's so
important to think about the foundations
of physics and so forth he's a tireless
advocate for the position of of
Foundations within the intellectual
spheres that we move in so it was
wonderful to get that aspect of his
thought represented when it comes to
quantum mechanics of course I was happy
to get you know the pro bomian point of
view which we've not had on the podcast
before we didn't talk that much about
his objections to everetti and quantum
mechanics but they're similar to other
people who have reasonable objections to
Everett you know whenever I give my
talks about many worlds I try to
distinguish between
objections to many worlds that are just
misunderstandings or not very coherent
versus objections that are actually you
know puzzles that are reasonable to fret
about we don't know what the final
answers are some theories are going to
be more promising for some reasons less
promising for others and every
individual researcher is going to
balance what they really care about now
you know I think Tim and I are great
pair in the sense that we do very much
disagree for reasons that are
interesting rather than just because he
doesn't understand it I mean as he says
in the podcast he would count Everett as
a perfectly respectable try at the
foundations of quantum mechanics he just
doesn't think it works mostly for
reasons about you know getting the
probability rule right and getting
structure out of the wave function
mapping it on to experience things like
that and these are very good things to
worry about I think that we can answer
those those worries but those are the
good worries that he has
um it's interesting because it reveals a
difference in how people come to these
things you know I I prefer to have a
theory that is super duper simple from
which in principle I can derive
complicated things rather than going all
the way to a theory that just adheres
very closely to the phenomena bohmian
Advocates like it because you know why
does the way why does quantum mechanics
sometimes have electrons acting like
particles sometimes like waves because
there are both particles and waves I
remember about a year ago Tim and I both
gave sort of competing talks at a little
workshop at Northeastern on foundations
of quantum mechanics I gave the
everettian Spiel he gave his bomine Etc
Spiel and I was celebrating the fact
that you know we had ways we thought to
derive the existence of space just from
the wave function and his reaction was I
just have space in my ontology it's it's
right there I don't need to derive it
and it's it's interesting because
I think it's good that we can derive it
from something more fundamental he
thinks it's good that it's just there he
doesn't need to worry about it you know
and it's it's right there so who knows
who will turn out to be correct in the
end
um you know just so it's clear because I
don't like to you know push my own
agenda too much on the podcast but I'm
not a fan of booming mechanics like Tim
thinks about Everett I think that Bohm
is a perfectly respectable try it's
absolutely worth considering but I do
think that those difficulties we touched
on in fitting modern Quantum field
Theory into the bohmian framework are
very very big difficulties I mean you'll
get very few particle physicists quantum
gravity people who are bomian people
there's a lot of booming people out
there but they're mostly either in
sort of quantum information type things
or even more in philosophy of physics
John Bell was a Bohemian because he he
liked the fact that it was very very
clear and crisp and you knew what was
happening you knew your way around it
wasn't vague and hard to understand like
Copenhagen was so I think Everett's the
way to go but I'm very glad that people
like Tim are working on the alternatives